[Musique]
nous ouvrons la voie et le plus grand
progrès humain de tous les temps, la
technologie qui coule dans ses veines
augmente sa force, ses réflexes et même
ses capacités de guérison,
il ne ressemble à rien de ce que nous avons vu auparavant
[Musique]
et il est entièrement sous notre contrôle à
partir de la mémoire  fabrication prochaine
mission dans trois deux un
et initier la séquence qu'est-
ce que je fais ici tu t'es fait
tuer
tu comptes sur la deuxième chance
tu as une armée en toi ils appellent
Ana sympa ils t'ont reconstruit et ceux-là sont
dans mon sang il y a
tes  sang,
bienvenue dans ton avenir
[Musique]
J'ai été manipulé sur ce que
tu penses réel parfois, n'est-ce pas j'ai
eu une femme et deux enfants pour moi
[Musique]
qui m'ont transformé en une arme
qu'ils n'ont aucune chance de faire exploser
oh mec
[Musique]
toi